nous entamons la dernière semaine
d'audition de cette commission d'enquête
consacrée à à l'échec des politiques
publiques de réduction de l'impact et
des usages des produits
phytopharmaceutiques nous avons deux
auditions prévues de cette semaine cette
semaine pas des moindres puisque il
s'agit de de deux ministres que nous
avons à auditionner et ce soir je suis
heureux d'accueillir monsieur Christophe
Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoirees monsieur le ministre merci
d'être parmi nous
euh nous vous auditionnons comme vous le
savez parce qu'il s'agit de d'avoir un
examen critique de politique publ
interministériel qui repose sur quatre
des plus grosses administrations
centrales et il y a un point particulier
que nous que nous
examinons que N nous explorons c'est la
dimension
interministériel de cette politique
publique sachant
que
il il apparaît et ce n'est pas le cas
particulièrement de cette politique là
que l'interministériel en France c'est
pas vraiment notre fort au sens où il y
a beaucoup d'arbitrage expost il y a
beaucoup de un grand nombre de
concertations ça n pas doutter c'est
quelque chose qui est
ressorti il manque peut-être de cohésion
préalable à la conduite de l'action
publique et en particulier de
hiérarchisation de différents objectifs
qui peuvent se concurrencer je pense que
vous allez pouvoir nous parler parce que
c'est particulièrement le cas de la
transition écologique il y a l'enjeu
carbone il y a l'enjeu climat il y a
l'enjeu haut il y a l'enjeu qui se
conjugue au sein du gouvernement avec
l'enjeu souveraineté alimentaire
protection du revenu agricole tout cela
n'est
pas forme un ensemble complexe et c'est
un point sur lequel nous souhaitons vous
entendre
donc nous allons vous demander de de
nous dire comment vous voyez comment
est-ce que vous êtes emparé comment
votre ministère s'est emparé de cette
cette question de la réduction des
produits phytopharmaceutiques comment
est-ce que vous vous en percevez la
cohésion l'articulation avec les
différents objectifs de vos collègues
évidemment agriculture mais aussi
recherche nous verrons si au taillot
demain
et j'ai oublié le 4e que nous avons
auditionné mais santé évidemment santé
évidemment puis que c'est complètement
au cœur donc voilà alors nous allons
nous allons vous écouter pour une
intervention liminire d'une d'une
dizaine de minutes euh à la suite de
quoi le rapporteur va réagir et nous
ouvrirons l'échange aux membres de la
commission euh présents mais avant je
vous rappelle que cette audition est
ouverte à la presse qu'elle est
retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale et qu'en vertu de
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des des assemblées parlementaires vous
êtes tenu de prêter serement de dire la
vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité et je vais donc vous demander de
lever la main droite et de dire je le
jure je le jure merci monsieur le
ministre et je vous laisse la parole
très bien merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président des grosailles
monsieur le le rapporteur
potier d'abord je peux saluer très
simplement votre initiative qui vise à
essayer de comprendre les raisons pour
lesquelles nous n'avons pas atteint les
objectifs que nous sommes fixés alors
même qu'il ont été répétés à plusieurs
reprises qu'ils l'ont été par des
majorités qui étaient différent dans
leur composition et que quand on regarde
le chemin qui a été parcouru au moment
où on met en place un nouveau plan
écofyo c'est d'autant mieux de se
demander ce qui dans les précédents n'a
pas été au rendez-vous avant de
complètement lancer celui que nous
sommes en train de finaliser vous me
permettrez d'un mot très
rapide de dire que bien
entendu ces plans sont ciblés sur la
réduction des usages des produits
phytopharmaceutiques mais il ne vous a
pas échappé vous l'avez d'ailleurs
évoqué vous-même dans votre intervention
liminaire monsieur le Président que nous
attendons la transition écologique en
matière d'agriculture pas seulement sur
les usages de produits mais sur beaucoup
d'autres thèmes que je évidemment
j'aurai pas l'occasion de développer
parce que c'est pas l'angle de votre
commission mais je pense évidemment à la
réduction des gaz à effet de serre à la
stratégie nationale
biodiversité aux enjeux d'adaptation
certains de ces sujets croisent la
question de l'usage des produits
phytopharmaceutiques je pense évidemment
à la question de la biodiversité mais je
pense qu'on aura l'occasion d'y revenir
d'autres pas nécessairement par exemple
en matière de stockage de carbone au
contraire une partie de ces produits
peut permettre d'éviter d'utiliser des
produits anique qui eux-mêmes peuvent
tasser les sols ou conduire à devoir
utiliser des moteurs thermiques pour
être capable dans des usages mécaniques
d'obtenir une partie des résultats qui
sont
recherchés la question de l'adaptation
concerne évidemment l'agriculture et
elle a un impact au travers de l'eau sur
la question des intrans puisque la
diminution de l'eau prélevable va
aboutir à une concentration accrue d'un
certain nom d'intran sur les points de
captage et montre bien la nécessité
qu'il y a sur ce sujet de faire en sorte
d'avancer j'ai bien compris que votre
sujet portait aussi
sur les améliorations du travail
interministériel pour le dire de cette
manière je je voudrais avec vous juste
en en me retournant sur le chemin
parcouru mesurer que chaque plan écofito
s accompagné d'un élargissement du
nombre de ministères concernés et donc
que le premier constat du plan écofito
était que le caractère purement
ministériel ne fonctionnait pas parce
qu'il convenait de faire en sorte qu'il
y a au moins un deuxième ministère qui
entre dans la danse et qui
historiquement a été le ministère de
l'Environnement au moment des cofito 2
et je ne peux pas imaginer que le
rapport du 23 décembre 2014 de celui qui
est notre rapporteur ce soir soit
totalement étranger y compris puis que
sa première préoccupation portait sur le
fait qu'il fallait pas seulement se
concentrer sur la question agricole mais
sur la question de la biodiversité que
nous avions dans ce domaine sans doute
besoin de davantage renseigner ce qui
était la conséquence sur les milieux en
particulier aquatiqu de l'ensemble de
ces éléments
etcopito
euh de plus euh en 2018 c'est élargi au
ministère de la santé et de
l'enseignement supérieur vous
remarquerez qu'à ce stade nous n'avons
pas prévu dans le cadre descofito 2030
de rajouter d'autres ministères à ce
nombre déjà conséquent et qui permett de
refléter toutes les dimensions qui sont
recherchées puisque la santé est
évidemment là contenu des impacts en
particulier
des de ces produits phytopharmaceutiques
classé CMR l'enseignement supérieur est
là pour au titre de la recherche faire
en sorte que nous puissions regarder
comment déployer des alternatives ou
améliorer le pter à connaissance y
compris d'ailleurs des des futures
générations d'agriculteurs des lycée
agricole et cetera mais je vais pas
aller là-dessus j'ai le sentiment que je
parle bien entendu au titre du ministère
de la transition écologique même si à
certains égards je peux vous assurer que
c'est un sujet qui préoccupe les élus
locaux et donc que la cohésion des
territoires peut aussi être impacté par
ces sujets en particulier sur la gestion
des des points de captage d'eau contenu
précisément de la compétence portée par
les commune aujourd'hui dans un certain
nombre de territoire par les
intercommunalités demain
et la situation de la biodiversité qui
fera l'objet de la présentation dans
quelques jours d'une stratégie nationale
qui sera une des premières déclinaisons
euh de la COP 15 elle repose sur un
constat d'érosion de la biodiversité
dont on sait que la première cause est
l'artificialisation mais assez vite
arrivent les impacts qui sont liés à
l'usage de produits phytopharmaceutiques
dans les causes de ces espèces menacé
avec des chiffres qui se recoupent je
pense aux population d'oiseaux en milieu
agricole quand on les compare par
rapport à ceux des villes je pense euh
aux insectes pollinisateurs et aux
mesures spécifiques qui ont été prises
compte tenu là aussi euh de leur
situation à une autre échelle quand on
se retourne sur les 15 ans qui
s'écoulent depuis ce premier plan euh éc
phyo pris en marche du Grenel on ne peut
que constater que le
niveau d'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires en 2022 correspond à
celui de 2008 si je vais
vite on est donc sur des engagements qui
ont consisté plusieurs fois à se dire
qu'on allait diminuer en volume et sur
une stabilité quand on garde sur une
longue période mais avec des période de
hausse puisque nous avons connu une
baisse au cours de ces dernières années
tout par particulièrement de ces
dernière années sur une partie de des
usages qui doit nous encourager à se
dire qu'on a peut-être enclenché en
terme de direction et en terme
d'ambition un nouveau niveau je veux
néanmoins souligner un succès objectif
de ces plans
écofyau quand on regarde les risques et
quand je regarde notamment les produits
qui sont classés cmr1 que ce soit en ODU
ou en QSA on a des reculs qui sont
spectaculaires en
pourcentage c'est moins vrai sur les
cmr2 où on tourne plutôt aux alentours
de 20 % quand on est entre 93 et 96
selon les unités qu'on mesure pour être
capable de regarder sur les sur les
cmr1 et donc euh très concrètement
j'ajoute
que je viens de beaucoup parler
d'agriculture la loi Lab a permis des
résultats sur les usages non agricoles
qui eux sont assez spectaculaire
puisqu'on est à plus de 95 % de
réduction sur les usages nonagricoles
des produits euh des produits
phytopharmaceutiques je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il soit utile de vous exprimer ce que
sont les attendus du plan écofyo 2030
parce que je pense que vous aurez des
occasions peut-être de me questionner
sur le sujet mais si je précise les murs
porteurs euh de de ce plan écofyo
d'abord c'est de rappeler cet engagement
d'une diminution de 50
%. ensuite c'est de consacrer des moyens
en face parce qu'on ne peut pas tenir un
discours qui consiste à expliquer qu'on
va diminuer les usages des produits
phytopharmaceutiques mais que on ne
laissera pas les gens sans solution si
on ne lance pas des programme de
recherche pour trouver des solutions et
qu'on se contente d'attendre le moment
où on constate qu'il y a une dangerosité
avérée pour se dire qu'il faut qu'on
lance les recherches on joue sur un
effet retard qui consiste à procrastiner
sur chacune des phases et donc c'est
bien en anticipant une partie de ces
programmes de recherche qu'on sera
capable d'obtenir des résultats de de
meilleure qualité j'ajoute que euh plus
largement je je pourrais évidemment
préciser des éléments sur les enjeux de
financement ce qui est prévu dans le
cadre du Plan haut j'en ai dit un mot
rapide doit être additionné à ce plan
écofito puisqu'il y a au travers des
moyens que nous consacrons aux agences
de l'eau mais aussi au travers de la
systématisation des pgse la volonté de
pouvoir faire en sorte d'avoir un suivi
des points de captage qui nous le savons
sont un des points de
faiblesse tout particulier d'un point de
vue sanitaire des dispositifs de
protection
[Musique]
et à ce
stade les le PLF qui arrive et qui va
consacrer l'augmentation des moyens des
agences de l'eau et bien le préalable à
des actions extrêmement concrètes qui
vont pouvoir
venir
accompagner les gestionnaires de
réseau je vais pas être beaucoup plus
long dans cette intervention liminaire
je préfère me concentrer sur les
questions sur les j'espère que je
pourrai satisfaire votre curiosité je
vous parlerai du recul de mon expérience
depuis juillet de l'année dernière ce
qui est à la fois beaucoup et et et peu
dans un certain nombre de domaines
pointus si vous entrez trop dans le
détail de certaines catégories mais je
suis à la disposition de la commission
d'enquête monsieur le Président Monsieur
le
Rapporteur merci monsieur le ministre
pour ses propos pour ses propos très
clairs concis qui vont effectivement
nous permettre de
avoir une bonne heure devant nous pour
pour pouvoir échanger monsieur le
rapporteur je vous laisse
réagir merci monsieur le Président
m'associer à vos remerciements du
ministre pour pour la clarté de de ses
propos une forme
d'humilité par rapport à la situation
que nous sommes en train d'observer et
puis nous avons apprécié c'était le cas
également du ministre de l'Agriculture
et et d'autres la bonne disposition du
gouvernement vis-à-vis de cette
commission d'enquête vous l'avez pris
positivement et et c'est ainsi que c'est
notre état d'esprit également on
voudrait être utile au débat public et
on arrive à un moment vous le savez où
il y a à la fois un plan écoofuto 30 qui
va être stabilisé un an après son
annonce donc début
2024 nous sommes c'est demain je crois
qu'il a le Parlement européen doit
adopter sa position sur le règlement sû
bon après le chemin est encore long mais
c'est une étape
importante et puis il y a également un
horizon euh qui va se dessiner pour un
nouveau programme de recherche européen
donc nous sommes un moment où notre
commission d'enquête peut faire des
propositions qui est des atterrissages
politique euh quasi dans les on va dire
dans dans dans les dans les mois et dans
dans l'année qui vient donc c'est plutôt
c'est plutôt c'est plutôt une chance et
on va dialoguer avec vous alors depuis
depuis pour tous les ministres qu'on a
pu rencontrer tous les ministres de
l'Agriculture euh vous on va pas vous
faire vous demander de justifier euh les
choix de Barbara pompelli d'éisabeth
borne de et de tous ceux qui ont qui ont
précédé qui ont été aux responsabilités
dans dans cette période donc vous allez
échapper à cet inventaire des
responsabilités sur 10 ans parce qu'on
peut pas vous faire porter tout cette
responsabilité par contre on va aller
mais vraiment le plus loin possible avec
vous pour comprendre votre perception de
de ce qu'on peut appeler quand même une
incurie une décennie un peu perdue quand
à la recherche des résultats même s'il y
a des bénéfices et on partage la liste
des bénéfices que vous avez établi on
pourrait même l'élargir je pense à la
prise de conscience je pense à à la
formation des agriculteurs au fond
phyovictimes et cetera il a il y a
vraiment des avancées mais globalement
on n'est pas on n'est pas au rendez-vous
la première question que j'ai envie de
de vous poser monsieur le ministre c'est
elle concerne le débat sur les objectifs
euh certains puisqu'on a échoué disent
ce qui était faux c'était ce qui était
mauvais c'éit les objectifs ils sont
trop ambitieux il faut il faut rester à
à Mo- 20 % dans dans 10 ans il faut être
très prudent et cetera à force de se
fixer un objectif inatteignable on finit
par désespérer le peuple bon est-ce que
c'est votre point de vue vu ou est-ce
que vous pensez au vu de toutes les
connaissances qui sont les votres que le
- 50 % na tardé à l'atteindre et qu'il
est urgent de de confirmer l'objectif du
gouvernement et de se donner les moyens
pour
2030 donc c'est comme ça question
réponse vous listez pas les questions
très bien
eu mon regret rétrospectif c'est qu'on n
pas fixé une cible sur les cmr1 de
manière à pouvoir montrer à la
population qu'on atteignait quand même
une partie des objectifs qu'on se fixait
si je suis transparent avec vous quand
je regarde le dossier aujourd'hui ce qui
m'a surpris comme ministre c'est de
découvrir que nous avions sur les
produits
cmr1 un tel taux de diminution et en
tant que citoyen j'entendais le discours
sur on ne va pas assez vite sur la
réduction des pesticides ma conviction
c'est que l'action publique elle se
nourrit d'objectifs ambitieux mais de
début de réalisation qui permettent de
mesurer que on est dans la bonne
direction et mon regret à postériorie
c'est qu'on nit pas eu un objectif
global sur les pesticides et un sur les
cmr1 et qu'on puisse dire regardez on a
un des deux objectifs qu'on a été
capable d'atteindre parce que ça aurait
donné de la confiance aux citoyens sur
le process en revanche
50 % c'est pas pour faire bien c'est pas
la recherche euh d'une sorte de de
chiffre magique qui frappe les esprits
et c'est pas totalement un hasard si il
y a un alignement aussi bien dans ce qui
sera discuté demain au Parlement
européen sur les 50 % d'usage et 50 % de
risque euh dans le cadre de sû et dans
le plan écofyo tel qu'on l'imagine c'est
parce qu'aujourd'hui on est capable de
documenter l'impact de ces
produits sur non seulement la santé dans
un certain nombre de cas mais et là je
reprends totalement ma casquette sur la
biodiversité et en particulier sur les
milieux aquatiques le constat dans ce
domaine il est malheureusement accablant
nous avons un million d'espèces à
l'échelle de la planète qui sont
menacées pas toutes par les produits
phyopharmaceutique mais on sait que la
part de la menace en particulier quand
on prend des populations et des
spécimens
euh d'espèces dans un certain nombre de
cas se corrèle avec une partie des
usages ce qui est vrai pour les oiseaux
où vous avez globalement une mortalité
infiniment plus élevé dans la partie
agricole que dans la partie urbaine que
dans la partie forestière recoupe des
cartes sur lesquelles nous savons que
les conséquences pour l'eau pour le sol
et pour l'air entraînent une partie de
ces difficultés et donc de manière très
concrète cette ambition elle correspond
aux engagements que nous devons tenir si
nous sommes sincères quand nous disons
que nous voulons préserver la
biodiversité merci pour cette réponse
donc 50 % comme cap et puis un regret
sur un indicateur intermédiaire qui
aurait donné le le moral au troupe qu'on
aurait pu mais justement me ferez une
transition idéale quand on quand on
regarde l'effet on est je sais pas
combien d'heures d'audition ce qui a
marché c'est deux
leviers c'est d'une part les retraits de
molécule pour les srins c'est pasant
c'est pas
l'agroécologie c'est pas le conseil aux
agriculteurs c'est pas le marché c'est
le retrait des
molécules et ce retrait des molécules
est lié à au travaux de la de l'fsa et
de l'ANS ces mêmes travaux qui ont été
contestés par des membres de votre
majorité et qui ont eu des expressions
pour le MO ambigues de la part du
ministre de l'Agriculture qui semblait
remettre en cause la loi de de 2014 et
notamment la modification du Code de
Santé publique qui attribu à l'an la
capacité d'évaluer de gérer les risques
en lieu et place du ministre de
lariculture et après coup de
l'interministérialité alors de façon
très claire puisque ça a été le moteur
numéro 1 de ce que vous nous partageons
tous comme la seule réussite probante
des dernières années la voie
réglementaire est-ce que vous pouvez
nous affirmer aujourd'hui comme l'a fait
votre collègue ministre de l'Agriculture
que vous ne remettez pas remettrez pas
en cause cette loi de 2004 14 et que si
par hasard une loi venant du Sénat je
pense à la loi ferme France arrivait
dans dans dans à l'Assemblée nationale
le gouvernement aurait un avis
défavorable je je n'ai aucune difficulté
pour vous répondre à titre personnel
j'ai aucune difficulté pour vous parler
pour vous répondre en tant que ministre
prendre l'engagement de ce que serait la
position du gouvernement même si je n'ai
aucun doute sur ce qu'elle serait me
conduirait à m'élever auus de ma
condition monsieur le rapporteur mais à
partir du moment où vous dites que que
ce soit le ministre de l'Agriculture ou
moi on est sur ses positions vous avez
quand même une petite idée de ce
pourquoi vous pourrions nous pourrions
aller euh donc bien entendu qu'il est
pas question de revenir sur un principe
qui consiste à faire confiance à la
science et à se baser sur les avis qui
sont rendus c'est aussi une des clés de
la transparence et de la confiance
vis-à-vis des citoyens ce qui complique
parfois l'analyse c'est le système à
double niveau avec des autorisations de
mise sur le marché des substances
actives qui relèvent d'abord de
l'échelon européen puis des procédures
nationales et avec ensuite des votes à
l'échelle européenne ou des positions
qui sont prises par la Commission sur la
base des avis ou des positions des
agences européennes parce que quand vous
avez des avis qui sont divergents entre
des agences européennes et des agences
nationales ça ça n'est pas de nature à
réconcilier le citoyen avec la science
me dis pas que je vous ai encore servi
une
transition si parce que avec vous et le
président et je n' donne pas notre
collègue annelord babo nous pour dans
une compétition du celui qui est le plus
européen bon et il nous est on a fait ce
rêve avec le le le président de la
commission je pense queord le
partagerait volontiers vu la tradition
politique à laquelle elle est attachée à
ce que demain il y ait dans le prochain
mandat européen une une harmonisation
plus complète qui tiennent compte bien
sûr des contextes pédoclimatiques et des
zonages qui existent parce qu'on a pas
la même politique au Portugal en
Lituanie ça on peut t le comprendre mais
par contre qu' a une harmonisation non
seulement de l'évaluation du risque mais
de la gestion du risque à échelle
européenne pour des questions de
crédibilité mais aussi de de de
diminution des distorsions de
concurrence entre nos producteur est-ce
qu'un tel dessin vous paraît pour le
moins
aimable je dois vraiment répondre à la
question de savoir si je trouve le
dessin aimable donc je je je vais
reformuler euh
un clairement un des sujets que nous
avons sont les distorsions de
concurrence entre nous mais je vais
aller un chouya plus loin c'est
potentiellement l'absence de close
miroir qui fait qu'on peut avoir des
débats sur les produits qu'on autorise
sur nos agriculteurs et qu'on laisse
passer nos frontières des produits
qui peuvent avoir été conçu
accompagnés traités avec une partie des
molécules que nous refusons devoir
appliquer chez nous donc là on a un
premier sujet global
de tout ce qui peut permettre de limiter
des distorsions de concurrence est
préférable parce que ça permet de faire
une pédagogie globale et éviter de se
retrouver avec des acteurs qui de bonne
fois se disent que pour des raisons
écologiques on va les conduire dans des
impasses économiques et vous mesurez
pleinement tout particulièrement contenu
de votre parcours la difficulté parfois
de bonne fois d'aller expliquer à des
agricurs qu'effectivement on a rajouté
des contraintes qui les concern qui ne
s'appliquent pas des concurrents qui
peuvent quand même vendre dans les
rayons de
supermarché là où j'aurais
peut-être un tout petit peu moins
d'enthousiasme que vous parce que quand
je regarde la chronologie des votes de
ces derniers mois au sein du Parlement
européen et en particulier la marge
particulièrement tenue avec le règle
avec lequel le règlement sur la
restauration de la nature est passé et
de la tonalité des discours qui sont
tenus au sein de cette enceinte je ne
suis pas
sûr que une harmonisation demain se
ferait uniquement sur la base du mieux
disant on sent aujourd'hui globalement
sur la transition
écologique
euh une tension avec de plus en plus de
députés européens ou de pays qui sont en
train d'exprimer que on en fait trop
qu'on va trop vite qu'on impose trop de
contraintte que notre continent par
rapport à ceux qui sont autour de lui
devrait ralentir ça a été extrêmement
prégnant avec des débats autour de la
restauration des zone humide ou de la
préservation d'une partie des espaces et
donc de ce point de vue autant je
souhaite qu'on ait des approches
européennes sur un maximum de sujets
aant je m'inquiète d'une tonalité
européenne qui pourrait être moins
favorable à la protection
l'environnement pour l'avenir que ce
qu'elle a été par le passé si je suis
totalement
transparent donc un idéal européen et
puis un
pragmatisme de de de souveraineté
nationale quand quand quand n quand la
politique française verrait une
régression par par par des lois
européennes c'est c'est c'est dur c'est
dur à porter politiquement cette
contradiction entre notre idéal et puis
le le réel mais on la comprends bien et
merci d'avoir d'avoir joué le jeu de
répondre à cette question qui est une
question de de pure prospective mais qui
pour pourit figurer comme une des
propositions du rapporteur nous sommes
en train de les
rédiger vous voulez ajouter quelque
chose un cas
pratique imaginons un sujet qui
concernerait le glyphosate monsieur le
rapporteur dans laquelle vous constatez
autour de la table que vous avez 17 pays
qui sont prêts à valider une proposition
de réautorisation pour 10 ans sans
aucune limitation alors que certains
États ont commencé un travail pour
regarder comment diminuer l'impact de ce
produit dont certains discutent de
l'impact en terme de santé mais dont
personne ne devrait discuter l'impact
sur la biodiversité sur les milieux de
manière générale et vous mesurez dans
l'immense difficulté à trouver un
consensus parmi les 10 États qui ne
votent pas en faveur de la proposition
de la Commission qui propose la
réautorisation pour 10
ans que même s'il y a un idéal européen
il se heurte à des positions à des
histoires ou à des posture dans un
certain nombre d'États qui rend plus
complexe qu'on le pense la non
régression environnementale même à cette
échelle merci alors encore une
transition voilà un des domaines où il y
a à la fois une politique européenne et
puis une très grande subsidiarité
nationale c'est la
PAC il y a des il y a beaucoup de débat
sur cette subsidiarité nationale he qui
qui apparaît pour certains comme une
régression en tout cas c'est un fait la
France a eu la faculté
d'écrire un parcours singulier pour ces
producteurs un contrat entre ces
producteurs et la nation or dans le plan
ecofyo 2 ecofyo 30 2030 pardon que vous
avez vous avez mis en débat figure la
volonté de d'engager alors lentement une
réflexion en 2024 en vue de 2025
peut-être et cetera ça nous paraît un
peu un peu un peu flou et lent mais le
simple fait que vous ayez inscrit un an
après sa mise en œuvre le besoin d'une
révision du PSN n'est-il pas un aveu que
ce PSN n'est pas à la hauteur des enjeux
écologiques que nous partageons et alors
ma question va être plus
précise et c'est vraiment à l'épreuve de
l'interministérialité alors pourvez nous
répondre comme le ministre de
l'Agriculture que c'est Guer mieux dans
les autres pays que des mesures
élitistes que personne ne prend que là
on a fait des mesures populaires mais
qui ne changeront rien et que finalement
on est dans la moyenne européenne mais
enfin ça fait pas ça fait pas une
politique et on n'est pas on n'est pas à
la hauteur des enjeux la vérité c'est on
aimerait vraiment que vous nous disiez
comment est-ce que le ministère de
l'écologie dans les débats qui ont
prévalu au moment de la la fixation des
règles du PSN a pesé ou est-ce qu'on a
eu un dialogue uniquement entre la
profession et le ministère de
l'Agriculture d'abord je finis sur le
début de votre
interpellation à l'occasion d'un des
derniers conseil
européens
juste après le vote le premier vote sur
la position de la Commission je me suis
retrouvé avec mes collègues membres de
l'écologie de l'environnement et tous
sont expliqué le fait que ils ne
pouvaient pas arrêter une position à
titre perso sans avoir consulté en inter
ministériel chez eux les ministres de
l'agriculture par rapport à ce que nous
pourrions décider donc de ce point de
vue et y compris dans des pays de plus
petite taille où on peut penser que
l'interministéalité fonctionne de façon
plus rapide j'ajoute que sans critique
mais
le moment que nous avons passé avec ce
conseil des ministres franco-allemands
et et ce temps avec nos homologues a
aussi permis de mesurer la complexité
qui pouvait y avoir là-bas sur des
sujets comparables au débat que nous
avons ici par exemple la question du
loup sur un sujet très lointain de celui
qu'on évoque entre le ministère de
l'écologie et le ministère de
l'agriculture en Allemagne fait
manifestement l'objet de débat à peu
près comparable à ceux que nous avons
chez nous dans des circonstances
différentes j'arrive au PSN et à la
place de du ministère de l'écologie non
l'interministérialité sur ce sujet où
aujourd'hui sur les PPP on est sur des
usages agricoles puisqu'on a banni les
autres au fur et à mesure du temps qui a
passé
elle elle consacre évidemment un rôle
important du ministère de l'agriculture
mais elle n'est pas de façade pour que
les autres ministères elle envoie au
chapitre c'est vrai pour les discussions
que nous avons entre nous en en terme
d'arbitrage et de prise de position
vis-à-vis de Matignon ça l'est dans les
débats qui entre ministres nous
conduisent à présenter pas seulement la
contribution de nos écosystèmes nos
convictions nos histoires le rapport
effectivement de de nos propres parties
de nos propres parties prenantes
et objectivement qu'on ait besoin
d'ajuster des politiques EUR PN c'est
d'autant moins surprenant qu'entre le
moment où on les conçoit et le moment où
on met on les met en application il y a
des lapses de temps qui sont liés au
temps pour se mettre d'accord à
l'échelle européenne et donc même si on
peut se dire quand même on lance une
révision alors que le dispositif a été
arrêté il y a peu de temps si vous
regardez la genèse de la PAC et le
moment où elle a été pensée et le moment
où dans la course de ha successive des
textes européens vous finissez par avoir
un dispositif qui
s'applique vous avez des mois et des
mois pendant lesquels la société a
continué à bouger pendant laquelle la
science a continué à bouger pendant
laquelle notre connaissance a continué à
bouger et au moment où vous enclenchez
une procédure vous savez que ça va à
nouveau prendre des mois avant que ça
fonctionne donc je soutiens évidemment
sans réserve cette cette
révision je la crois logique et plutôt
rassurante sur le fait que on est
précisément des politiques qui ne
s'ignorent pas qu'on tienneent compte de
ce qu'on dit dans nos plans écophyo et
que ça n'est pas juste une façon de de
répondre à une sorte de pression
citoyenne mais que ça ça correspond à
une vérité enfin un engagement à une
volonté sincère de
diminution Si Al vous vous avez coopéré
à ce PSN dont tout le monde aujourd'hui
admet à peu près scientifique ONG et
même les syndicats de mimau que ils vont
pas changer les pratiques agécologiques
de façon significative il y avait une
opportunité c'est qu'on a des problèmes
financiers pour payer tout le monde des
problème de paiement il a fallu revoir
les critères on aurait pu estimer que
c'était peut-être le moment de de
pousser un un peu les feux sur sur sur
la biou sur les MAEC sur différents
sujets et cetera et au lieu de ça on a
une diminution homogène de l'ensemble
des dispositifs de l'échorégime alors
que déjà on était renseigné sur le fait
que les changements opérés n'étaient pas
à la hauteur des enjeux écologiques qui
qui sont des dans l'intérêt même des
agriculteurs est-ce que sur une telle
décision euh vous êtes sur une décision
commune avec le ministère de
l'agriculture ou est-ce que c'est une
gestion déléguée au ministère de
l'Agriculture
par
définition ce qui est interministériel
et ça n'est pas une une lub ou un slogan
fait l'objet de discussion entre la
totalité des ministères concerné et
d'arbitrage à la fin qui relève du seul
moyen de trancher l'interministérialité
c'est-à-dire au niveau de Matignon la
mise en œuvre ensuite et la place
prééminente que joue naturellement le
ministère de l'Agriculture n'échappe à
personne mais ne nous empêche pas faire
valoir nos arguments et de les présenter
et de considérer d'ailleurs qu'on a
encore des marges d'amélioration sur
cette révision de des
PSN on peut objectivement considérer que
les cahiers des charges souffrent
peut-être d'un peu trop de complexité
sur les ambitions que on peut être
plus plus ambitieux sur les
augmentations des
mesures agroenvironnemental et de la
façon dont on pourrait effectivement
financer des choses qui permettraient
d'aller plus loin l'histoire est pas
totalement écrite monsieur le rapporteur
vous le
savez cas sur l'arbitrage tel qu'il a
été rendu il donne aucun avantage au
mesure qui aura un effet agroécologique
donc c'est c'est là cette révision
budgétaire est une occasion perdue mais
on entend la volonté de de revenir sur
ce sur ce PSN je vais vous interroger
sur un autre dispositif qui a bénéficié
du du
PSN c'est le la haute valeur
environnementale j'ai demandé euh avoir
l'ensemble des pièces des débats euh qui
ont prévalu aux décisions concernant HVE
je fais partie de ceux qui pensaient que
sur le principe c'est un levier
important vous pouvez pas
conditionnaliser conditionner pardon euh
l'évolution
agroécologique simplement au marché de
la bio et qu'il fallait qu'il fallait
une étape qui soit accessible à un grand
nombre d'agriculteurs pour enclencher
une démarche agroécologique mais dans la
définition dans la taxonomie qui a été
retenue pour HVE il y a il y a plusieurs
possibilités d'intervention et ces
possibilités d'intervention dans leur
diversité permettent de se distraire de
celle qui concerne directement
l'ambition en matière de réduction de la
phytopharmacie est-ce que vous avez un
regret quant aux arbitrages que vous
avez rendu qui rendu votre ministère je
ne sais pas si vous étiez là à ce
moment-là qui a été rendu par le
ministère de l'écologie c'est un sujet
qui a été beaucoup investi par le
ministère de l'écologie est-ce que vous
avez un regret aujourd'hui sur le fait
que HVE tel qu'on la fournit n'enclenche
pas vraiment le mote ur de la réduction
de la
phytopharmacie
euh plusieurs éléments de
réponse d'abord je n'ai pas été associé
personnellement au label pour une
question de calendrier date pas pour une
question fonctionnel pour vous répondre
euh ensuite j'entends dans votre
intervention et dans votre réponse que
vous avez vous à titre personnel évolué
sur le
sujet ma réponse est la suivante on a
besoin de miser sur l'agroécologie on a
besoin de miser sur le bio on a besoin
de faire progresser tout ce qui nous
permet de
diminuer les intrants de diminuer la
pression sur les ressources et la
planification écologique elle repose sur
un doublement des surfaces bio en 2030 y
compris pour des questions de
préservation de la biodiversité
d'atténuation
d'adaptation mais on peut pas on
pourrait pas se satisfaire de l'idée
qu'on aurait 20 % des gens qui seraient
en bio et 80 % des agriculteurs qui
auraient pas bougé qu'on ait des labels
qui poussent à faire en sorte de
regarder comment on c'est pas ce que je
dis que vous dites mais c'est ma réponse
et donc très et donc très
concrètement je considère que des labels
comme cella ils permettent de bouger ils
permettent d'aller faire en sorte
d'enclencher des mouvements une des
difficultés dans l'agriculture notamment
quand on la compare par rapport à
l'industrie sur les changements et sur
les évolutions de modèle un c'est qu'on
joue sur du vivant de c'est qu'on a un
âge moyen des exploitants qui permet
parfois de comprendre pourquoi certains
investises passent la marche ou d'autres
n'entam pas des processus de conversion
qui n'uront pas nécessairement le temps
d'amortir pour des raisons qui sont y
compris les raisons économiques et
tr c'est de bien prendre en compte
derrière que on a des réalités de marché
on doit donc évidemment se pencher sur
les conditions des labels mais se
préoccuper aussi que ceux qui sont
vertueux bénéficie des décisions que
nous prenons et ça c'est l'application
des Galim c'est le suivi très
concrètement de la part de bio dans les
cantines pour qu'on puisse faire en
sorte de renforcer le dispositif c'est
le fait d'éviter des importations qui ne
sont bonnes ni pour l'écologie ni pour
le revenu de d'une partie de nos
agriculteurs en faisant attention aux
accords que nous passons d'un point de
vue international et tous ces éléments
ensuite ils seront de nature à
crédibiliser les ambitions sur le cahier
des charges je veux juste témoigner
d'une chose c'est que je suis frapper
dans les rencontres à leur demande que
j'ai pu avoir avec les jeunes
agriculteurs de la façon dont on a une
génération qui est en train d'arriver et
qui se préoccupe pas du mot ou du label
mais qui se préoccupe de prendre le
wagon de la transition de façon
effective et
concrète deux questions encore pour
laisser un collègue au président la
capacité à vous interroger j'en ai plein
d'autres mais il faut je veux leur
laisser cette cette
possibilité vous avez
été au premier plan investi auprès de
Antoine payon dans son exercice de de
planification et j'ai j'ai j'ai
l'occasion de de saluer même comme
député de l'opposition le le travail
remarquable qui a été fait un travail
d'une métrique une recherche d'une
cohérence comment est-ce qu'on bouclait
le cycle du carbone celui de la biomasse
celui de du cycle de l'azote et cetera
enfin c'est c'est un travail qui qui est
assez remarquable je dois l'interroger
prochainement on doit on doit s'appeler
on doit se rencontrer s'il fallait
saisir des documents mais j'espère qu'on
peut s'épargner cette ce moment-là mais
j'aimerais savoir exactement comment la
question de la phytopharmacie et sa
diminution a été mis en cohérence avec
les autres objectifs qui sont ceux de la
décarbonation qui sont ceux dere
souveraineté alimentaire et et des
besoins en biomasse pour l'énergie
est-ce que vous avez le souvenir d'avoir
participé à des débats où ces enjeux
étaient étaient parfois en contradiction
je le dis parce que dans la société
civile
court cette petite musique que la
priorité c'est la décarbonation et que
finalement sur les phitos on pourrait un
peu lever le
pied passer enfin le mettre en second
plan est-ce que ce type de de de
questions qui sont qui sont des
questions extrêmement complexe difficile
à résoudre vous avez eu à participer à
des arbitrages ou à comprendre comment
est-ce que la trajectoire proposé
permettait de concilier réellement le -
50 % souveraineté alimentaire décarbon
production de biomasse et ce et ce je
poursuivrai avec Antoine P mais
j'aimerais avoir la version de
Christophe
B bon c'est une question compliquée
parce que c'est un an de boulot c'est
des dizaines de réunions avec pour
certaines un vrai lead objectif quand on
était sur des enjeux de transition
écologique pour d'autres des temps
partagés là aussi en interministériel
avec d'autres ministres et puis pour
certains des temps qui se sont passés où
j'ai été plus comment dirais-je plus
spectateur d'acteurs d'une partie des
discussions hyper techniques sur une
partie des filières si je résume sur les
questions qui dépendent de mon périmètre
ministériel que sont les transports que
sont les bâtiments on a produit des
propositions on a discuté des
hypo on a négocié potentiellement ce que
pouvait être des des souhaits d'aller
dans telle ou telle direction on a
discuté des sous-jacent budgétaire qui
rendaient crédible le fait d'aller
imaginer un nombre de rénovation un
accompagnement des collectivités
territoriales et cetera ensuite il y a
un champ sur lequel on a beaucoup
travaillé avec le ministère de
l'Agriculture qui est la question de la
biomasse parce que la forêt elle est au
croisement du stockage de la
préservation de la biodiversité et comme
il n'y a pas que la question de
l'atténuation dans la planif mais qu'il
y a également la question de la
stratégie nationale de biodiversité et
la question de l'adaptation du 4 degrés
et donc des îlots de fraîcheur enfin je
vous fais pas tout l'article mais qui
compte là-dessus on a eu pas mal
d'échanges et puis indirectement sur les
biodéchets sur la capacité à les
produire potentiellement du compost qui
relève des collectivités territoriales
et qui peut remplacer une partie en
terme d'engrais de ce qu'on peut
imaginer par ailleurs il y a eu quelques
points de jonction en
revanche je n'ai pas personnellement
participé à un temps sur la trajectoire
des produits phytopharmaceutiques reliés
à la planification écologique de façon
concrète on a rapidement évoqué pour
autant que je m'en souvienne une des
questions sur les productions de ces
engrais sur la manière dont on les
importait sur les conséquences
potentielles par rapport à ceux qui les
fabriquent mais c'était marginal par
rapport aux questions que vous posez qui
sont plus précises sur la contribution
effective
je je regrette parce que par exemple sur
la question de la trajectoire de
diminution des engrais azotés qui est
très lié à la maîtrise de la
phytopharmacie ça fait des années ça
commencé avec Julien Normandie on l'a
alerté plusieurs fois dans le Parlement
mais il faut commencer tôt sinon ça va
être une on va tomber devant un mur un
jour on acceptera plus cette dépenses
fossile des effets exra et cetera on va
avoir un problème de souveraineté
pétrole on va avir gaz on va avoir un
problème de d'effet sur sur sur sur sur
le dérèglement climatique donc il faut
anticiper ce sujet or dans la loi climat
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait on a dit il
faudrait commencer à réfléchir à
bricoler enfin et cetera c'est donc il y
a pas eu des débats dans la trajectoire
trans écologique comment est-ce qu'on
maîtrisait les engris à Sautter sous
leurs différentes formes de pour
maîtriser les phyos comment est-ce qu'on
gardait la biomasse néanmoins nécessaire
c'est sujets absolument capitaux et
c'est c'est directement des sujets
énergie et climat donc je vous en fais
pas le reproche mais je vais encore une
fois je vais poursuivre parce qu'on
aimerait dans le rapport voir si ces
questions ont été traitées par le
gouvernement à un endroit ou l'autre et
qu'on peut dire que effectivement non
seulement il faut diminuer les phitos
mais il faut engager cell des engrais
azotés sinon on aura on va se retrouver
devant quelque chose de violent qui va
nous arriver à force de pas traiter le
sujet il va il va rejaillir par la force
des choses et ça va être violent et et
que néanmoins on allit nourrir une
partie non seulement les français pour
contribuer au récit européen et voir
méditerranéen de la de la nourriture et
cetera ça ça nous rassurait terriblement
d'avoir des des éléments de rassurance
sur ces
points votre question n'était pas de
savoir si le gouvernement s'était penché
sur la réduction des engraisôé en
trajectoire du fait de savoir si j'avais
personnellement participé à la
discussion de la trajectoire donc ma
réponse il y a 50 de levier dans la
planification écologique on ent dans des
degrés de détail qui sont importants
là-dessus sur la question des engrais il
y a eu compris des discussion de mémoire
avec le ministère de l'Industrie parce
qu'on est sur de la production
exactement sous l'angle que vous
décrivez qui est l'angle de la
souveraineté et là tout finit par bouclé
la question d'un zéro artificialisé sur
Net qui évite d'aller bouffer des
espaces agricoles dont on aura besoin en
terme de souveraineté dans un contexte
ou contenu des ressources il faut pas
s'attendre à des progressions
nécessaires et des augmentations de
rendement à l'hectare avec des
ressources qui vont être diminuantes et
je pense en particulier à l'eau donc
avec des modes de production qui doivent
être plus sobre et avec l'assurance de
pouvoir se les fournir en circuit court
auou près de chez nous tout ça fait bien
l'objet de bouclage dans le cadre de la
planification écologique en revanche ce
ne sont pas des sujets sur lequels mon
ministère a été proactif sur le fait
d'aller amener des solutions on avait
déjà un peu plus de 50 % de la
trajectoire sur lequel c'était à nous
d'aller expliquer les types de de
gisement qu'on repérait et d'avoir des
discussions avec le sgpe pour croiser à
la fois leurs analyses les besoins
budgétaires et la place des
collectivités territoriales dans le
bouclclage Global croyez-moi ça nous a
déjà pas mal occupé je trouve cruel que
vous avez parlé du du zan parce qu'on a
pas le temps de développer je pourrais
pas vous dire tout le mal que je pense
de la loi qui a été adopté mais c'est
c'est c'est hors sujet donc on va voilà
mais j'aurais préféré que vous nen
parliez pas euh revenons sur un sujet
qui est directement sous votre autorité
qui est capital qui je le dis comme
rapporteur on arrive à la fin de nos
travaux et celui qui m'a le plus
bouleversé parce qu'on avait le rapport
de l'incerme qui nous alertait sur les
effets santé on savait les effets
biodives on connaissait mais vous l'avez
dit vous-même les milieux aquatiques et
et la sécurité d'accès à l'eau potable
et aujourd'hui en danger par le double
effet des règlements climatiques et
concentration des pollutions qualité
quantité vont se rencontrer avec des
effets tragiques moi je suis étonné euh
al quelques questions sur l'eau rapide
euh parce que on y reviendra s'il faut
mais je encore une fois je vauxis être
sûr que le président puisse vous
interroger et norbabo sur l'eau le seul
chiffre que vous donnez euh dans le
document du gouvernement et forcément il
vient de votre ministère c'est celui
d'une étude de 2015 2016 des inspections
j'imagine de votre ministère et associé
à d'autres est-ce qu'on a pas de
référence plus récente que 2015 pour
évoquer le coût de la pollution de l'eau
Mo ça m'a vraiment surpris quoi parce
que c'est c'est un sujet alors est-ce
qu'on dispose d'études des inspections
ou d'études ministérielles ou d'un
centre de recherche je sais pas quoi de
quelque chose de plus documenté que 2015
ça fait quand même 8 ans et entre-temps
on voit les effets du dérèglement j'ai
eu des informations aujourd'hui sur la
forêt qui sont qui sont pas des bonnes
nouvelles ça serait pire que ce qu'on
avait prévu et cetera sur sur l'ou on
mesure chaque
année les effets les effets terribles et
cetera donc est-ce qu'on peut quand on
fait un plan écofyo 2030 se référer à
des études de 2015 sans avoir mieux
documenté ces questions à la fois du
coût public et des risques avérés pour
la sécurité alimentaire de nos
concitoyens l'été de mon arrivé j'ai eu
vécu au première loges un épisode de
sécheresse qui m'a conduit à mesurer ce
qui étit les trous dans la raquette en
matière de politique
deau quand vous n'avez aucune remontée
en temps réel des communes qui sont par
exemple confronté à des difficultés
d'eau potable parce que ça c'est géré
par
Laars vous voulez parler
d'interministérialité et que il n'y a
pas de remontée parce que vous êtes sur
un ministère santé avec une avec des
chiffres la mission d'inspection a
d'ailleurs assez bien documenté ce qui
est qui était ce que nous devions
améliorer et le rétex qu'on en a fait
dans la foulée immédiate à l'automne
dernier a nourri le plan haut et les
mesures annoncées le 30
mars je donne cet
exemple l'absence d'actualisation du
coût de la pollution est tout à fait
exact et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous lançons une mission IGF IGAS de
manière à pouvoir précisément disposer
de chiffres actualis exactement pour les
raisons que vous êtes en train de dire
d'autant que moi j'ai c'est vrai pour la
forêt c'est vrai pour l'eau c'est vrai
dans beaucoup de domaines une obsession
une marotte qui est que nous puissions
renseigner nos concitoyens sur le coût
de l'inaction on discute dans beaucoup
de politiques de qu'est-ce qu'on doit
faire vous rendez compte ça coûte cher
ça représente temps quand vous mesurez
ce que coûte le fait de ne rien faire
dans un certain de domaines et ça peut
être vrai pour de la dépollution ça peut
être vrai pour de la prévention ça peut
être vrai pour du curage vous vous
rendez compte à quel point nous n'avons
pas un débat dans lequel on a tous les
éléments pour être capable de décider
parce que le coûpt de l'inaction est
relativ vise parfois le coût de l'action
ou en tout cas il l'objective donc c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous actualisons
euh cette ce coûp y compris pour demain
dans nos politiques d'adaptation montrer
la rationalité qu'il a augmenter nos
budgets de lutte ou les
dispositifs de responsabilité de metteur
sur le marché sur les plein de sujets la
question par exemple des microbilles de
plastique je vais pas entrer dans un
certain nombre de détail parce que là on
parle des produits phytopharmaceuqu
malheureusement l'eau et les milieux
aquatiques sont aussi attaqués par
d'autres types de pollution qui ont
elles-même des cûpts et qui nécessitent
là aussi qu'on soit capable d'avoir des
des évolutions de pratique ou des
mesures de REP
spécifiques du plan écouto 2030 qui
évidemment sont sont articulés on a vu
des propositions relativement
audacieuses en matière de protection des
captages je vous avoue qu'elles nous
paraissent pas suffisamment
ambitieuses j'évoque par exemple le
sujet de du droit de
préemption droit de préemption c'est
vous êtes élu vous savez aussi bien que
nous que c'est quand il y a il y a une
vente mais autrement on n pas voilà
est-ce qu'il faudrait pas aller plus
loin il y a toute une série de mesures
Aué et cetera enfin on les a bien vu on
a vu deux fois les agences donc on
connait bien tout ça mais on se dit
vraiment en matière de captage il y a
des territoires où ça fait une décennie
parfois deux décennies qu'on met de
l'argent public qu'on négocie qu'on
tergiverse on a pu ces annéesl devant
nous parce qu'on va manquer d'eau d'eau
potable bon est-ce que à un moment donné
la puissance publique doit pas faire
preuve de plus d'autorité et ne pas
laisser les préfet sous la pression des
acteurs locaux est-ce qu'une certaine
verticalité ou dans intérêt général ne
devrait pas s'exprimer à ce moment-là
est-ce que des procédures un peu plus
unifié à l'échelle nationale ne devrait
pas avoir
cours
j'entends mais il y a une mesure qui est
extrêmement ambitieuse et qu'elle est
potentiellement la base ensuite de
d'autres décisions qui pourraent être
pris
c'est l'obligation que chaque captage
dispose d'un pgse nous n'avons pas
aujourd'hui sur une part significative
des captage d' potable de ce pays de
plans de gestion sanitaire qui
permettent de façon concrète d'avoir des
résultats significativ et donc parfois
de pouvoir prendre des mesures
appropriées la systématisation des pgse
qui est une des mesures du plan qui n'a
pas été spécialement reprise parce que
je cont tenu du contexte tout le monde
s'est focalisé sur les enjeux de entité
de façon logique parce que cet
épisode avec ces 95 départements dans
lequels il y a eu des arrêtés
préfectoraux 75 où on a réduit à la Seu
eau potable les dispositifs 1000
communes privé d'eau avec du cernage ou
des
bouteilles fait que ça a été vécu comme
étant la fin de l'abondance et le fait
qu'il allit falloir faire 100 ou avec
moins mais il y a toute une partie du
plan qui porte sur la qualité sur le
fait que nous avons plus de la moitié de
nos masses d'eau qui ne sont pas en bon
état écologique et que toutes les
perspectives que nous avons sur sur la
diminution des masses d'eau va renforcer
la difficulté d'une manière totalement
mécanique et donc elle va pousser pour
qu'on a effectivement à partir de ces
indicateurs et de ce caractère très
objectif des mesures ça va de la
préhenstion je vous me permets quand
même de vous rappeler que nous évoquons
aussi par exemple des projets de
conversion à l'agroécologie qu'on est
pas uniquement dans des logiques de
sanctuarisation avec des crédits avec
des crédits qui sont en face qui sont
dans le plan haut et qui vont servir à
son financement c'est le augmentation de
la redevance pour pollution diffuse qui
figure dans le PLF actuel pour aussi
qu'on fasse en sorte de pas être
seulement dans une logique où on se
demande comment on utilise de l'argent
public pour aller contrer les effets
d'une politique dont on veut réduire une
partie des conséquences donc on est sur
quelque chose d'équilibrer avec des
mesures pour faire en sorte
d'accompagner les gestionnaires de
proximité et d'autres pour aller
augmenter la redevance pour pollution de
manière à limiter la
cause
monsieur le ministre pour ma part il y a
trois points sur lesquels qui ont été
abordés en fait sur lesquels je
souhaiterais revenir pour juste pour
creuser un tout petit peu s'agissant de
vision partagée entre les
administrations centrales concerné au
premier chef par ces enjeux de de de
transformation
euh là je parle en tant que
ancien directeur de d'interpro société
civile je peux témoigner du fait que
euh lorsque vous travaillez dans le
secteur agricole vous avez je rebondis
sur le fait que vous avez évoqué une
rencontre avec les jeunes agriculteurs
ce que je trouve en soi super que le
ministre de transition écologique
rencontre un syndicat agricole lorsque
vous travaillez dans ce dans ce secteur
là vous êtes pas le bienvenu au
ministère de transition écologique au
ministère de la santé c'est du vécu hein
euh que son les administrations centrale
tel que moi j'ai pu le percevoir et y
compris comme députés depuis depuis
quelques années qui que je perçois comme
rival et qui font arbitrer par le
Premier ministre des positions
qui sont souvent à la base pas
consciliiables donc ma question elle va
porter sur un point précis est-ce
que en tant que ministre de la
transition écologique vous considérez
qu'il faut aller vers une agriculture
qui se passe totalement de chimie où
est-ce que vous pensez que
l'objectif y compris de
reconceptualisation des systèmes de
réintroduction de polyculture élevage de
de tout ce travail avec ce qu' évoqué le
rapporteur sur le cycle de l'azote
d'autonomie protéique de notre paysage
agricole il pourra quand même il ne faut
pas renoncer à l'idée que le recours à
la chimie puisse être pertinent puisse
être utile le glyphosate est
emblématique de cette question vous
l'avez évoqué dans votre propos liminire
euh vous le savez très bien euh un
produit c'est c'est toute la différence
entre la ris le risque et le danger
l'exposition au danger qui est le risque
et ça sera ma deuxè question je vais
d'abord vous laisser répondre à celle-là
le politique peut décider que cette
exposition au danger sous certaines
conditions de façon réglementée peut
être acceptable parce que souhaitable
pour l'intérêt général donc est-ce que
par exemple justement le glyphosate peut
être utile pour cette transformation
agro
dans certains cas avec des restrictions
d'usage drastique un durcissement de tas
de point de vue des politiques publiqu
de de de recours au produits
phytopharmaceutiqu dit autrement à la
chimie votre position et votre ministère
fait-il arbitrer par le Premier ministre
un écart entre une administration
centrale qui pousse vers une agriculture
sans chimie et une autre qui pousse pour
faire valoir que le recours à la chimie
on s'en passera
jamais
ok vu les
niveaux
auquel nous sommes en terme d'usage il y
a
loin par rapport à un monde agricole
dans lequel il y aurait zéro
chimie si on tient ce plan écofito avec
cette baisse de 50 % je nous donne
rendez-vous quels que soi les
responsabilités qu'on occupera pour
savoir combien de marche de 50 % on est
encore capable de faire contte tenu d'un
certain d'usage pour lesquels
aujourd'hui S chimie nous n'avons pas de
réponse et pour lesquelles une approche
simpliste pourrait consister à dire on a
qu'à tout supprimer sauf que la réalité
à laquelle nous sommes soumis y compris
parfois pour aller limiter d'autres
impacts environnementaux qui sont liés
aux alternatives à la chimie peuvent
exister j'ai rapidement évoqué la
question mécanique la question du
tassage des sols et cetera euh en
revanche de bonne foi on ne peut pas
contester aujourd'hui qu'on a une
dépendance à la chimie qui est trop
grande à des produits qui dont la
dangerosité n'est pas seulement
potentielle mais avérée et donc qu'on a
des marges considérables d'amélioration
avec des auxiliaires avec des schémas de
culture combinées avec euh des
programmes de recherche alternative avec
du biocontrôle chaque mois c'est euh en
moyenne six solutions de biocontrôle
supplémentaires qui sont mises sur le
marché pour faire en sorte de d'avoir
des alternatives et des choses qui
progressent donc euh de là où je vous
parle avec l'horizon temporel qui est le
mien aussi loin que je regarde et ça va
pas très loin au-delà de 2030 c'est déjà
presque manqué d'humilité que de savoir
comment se terminera la décennie comp
tenu de la vitesse à laquelle vont
certaines
choses je ne vois pas une agriculture
dans laquelle on se passe totalement de
chimie mais je vois des marges de
diminution qui sont telles que ça vaut
le coup de se concentrer sur
elle merci très clair du coup dans le
prolongement ma question porte sur le
rôle du politique et je voudrais revenir
sur la loi de 2014 évoquée par le
rapporteur
et là-dessus tout à fait siamment je je
fais valoir un un point de vue différent
de de devec une nuance diraisje de celui
qui qui a été évoqué par le rapporteur
cette loi de 2014 a le le mérite évident
de renforcer la confiance que pe avir
les concitoyens dans la décision de mise
en marché de la décision de la gestion
du
risque pour la en la confiant à une
agence indépendante et vous l'avez même
évoqué il sera jamais question de
remettre en courseuse le rôle de la
science d'un autre point de vue
le la gestion du risque est une décision
politique et on est nécessairement
s'agissant de gérer le risqueexposition
en danger sur une approche de ce qui est
acceptable confier la décision ce qui
est acceptable à une agence indépendante
don la question se savoir devant qui
elle est responsable ça participe aussi
du discrédit du politique et
paradoxalement la crise de confiance
dans les élus dans les institutions
quelle est votre position
làdessus
on est dans une question qui est à la
fois très philosophique et très
politique qui me permet aussi de
m'échapper de ma responsabilité parce
que c'est pas en tant que ministre que
je vais vous répondre c'est c'est
vraiment en tant que
citoyen il y a une
part je considère qu'à la fin la
décision doit revenir au politiqu pour
une raison très
simple c'est que sinon on accélérera une
forme de discr ID scientifiques dans un
certain nombre de cas parce qu'on a'ura
pas euh parce que personne n'assumera la
décision et que tout le monde se
repassera la patate chaude si si je dois
vous répondre de manière un peu trivial
voilà très exactement ce que je dirais
et que il arrive parfois qu'en terme de
science et de ce point de vue le covid
en a été un exemple que tous les
scientifiques soient pas d'accord entre
eux et la nuance elle se trouve dans le
probable dans le potentiel ou dans le
avérer euh dans le degré de risque qui
est associé
à une intensité d'exposition à une
présence à une distance les paramètres
sont tels qu'à la fin qui a une instance
qui tranche et qu'elle bénéficie d'une
légitimité démocratique pour faire ça ça
me semble souhaitable je ne crois pas à
un monde dans lequel celui qui assume la
responsabilité c'est celui qui a eu la
meilleure note au concours je pense que
il est souhaitable au contraire d'être
dans une logique ù celui qui décide il
le fait en prenant en compte
l'intégralité des
paramètres là aussi clair merci pour
votre réponse 3ème point puis j' au
membres de la commission présent
s'agissant de l'harmonisation européenne
euh et tant qu'à faire de rêver hein
puisque nous n sommes pas privés de
rêver avec le rapporteur cette question
euh sachant que
euh vous l'avez évoqué je je je je
précise juste au passage évidemment on
ne peut pas à la fois prétendre être le
meilleur élève de la classe et avoir le
sens du compromis requis pour qu'il y
ait une harmonisation donc ce que vous
évoquez en disant il est à craindre que
si une harmonisation ça soit pas aligné
sur les exigences françaises de l'ANS et
sur ce que nous avons fait sur
glyphosate c'est quelque chose dont je
pense qu'il est important d'avoir bien
conscience et de le dire est-ce qu'on
peut rêver d'un troisième pilier de la
PAC adaptation réchauffement transition
agroécologique je vous le dis parce que
quel chose qui est revenu ces dernières
années compris de la part de certains
députés européens euh il a été évoqué le
PSN nous le savons très bien les
ministres de l'Agriculture ont toutes
les peines du monde à arbitrer entre les
différentes finères agricoles sur ce qui
va être prè du pilier 1 du pilier
2 pour modifier changer les règles du
jeu et on peut quand même se dire que
face à l'ampleur de la mutation qui est
attendue de toute façon comme vous le
dites avec le coup de l'inaction
l'ampleur de cette mutation forcée
puisque les projections du JEC nous
laisse penser que il y a un C nombre de
cultures qui vont au moinsêtre déplacer
du Sud vers le
Nord cont tenu de cette ampleur là
est-ce que c'est de la science-fiction
est- que c'est quelque chose qui
pourrait être mis sur la T dans les
années qui viennent que d'imaginer
un un plus gros budget européen pour
financer un troè
pilier
alors
d'abord on a un enjeu
euh avant de discuter du pilier de la
PAC je vais vraiment le redire avec
beaucoup de de de simplicité beaucoup de
force
mais nous ne pourrons pas continuer à
autant importer en Europe de produits
agricoles qui viennent de l'extérieur
tout en prétendant ne pas faire preuve
d'une forme d'hypocrisie
environnementale ou écologique que ce
soit en terme de bilan carbone en terme
de réglementation moi je j'ai beaucoup
de mal à comprendre qu'on ne soit pas
beaucoup
plus clair sur les clauses
miroir il y a eu un règlement parti
particulièrement courageux dans ce
domaine de lutte contre la
déforestation avec un contrôle par
satellite dans lequel on dit nous allons
exiger d'un certain nombre de pays tiers
qui puisse délivrer les certificats
d'importation reposant sur la certitude
que ça n'est pas sur la déforestation
que du caoutchou de l'huile de palme de
la viande de bœuf a été produite àir les
récriminations des Brésiliens
aujourd'hui et sans doute contenu de la
personnalité du président argentin et
Luu hier des Argentins sont trop tardés
sur ce type de
sujet
la tentation d'un certain nombre de pays
européens de ratifier l'accord de libre
jange
mercossour les débats que nous avons
parfois en Europe entre nous alors qu'on
est dans un contexte où on ne mesure pas
que la première des urgences c'est de
limiter des échanges mondiaux sur ces
sujets pour pouvoir discuter avec nos
agriculteurs dans un cadre dans lequel
la question de leur revenus et de leur
pratique se discute sans distorsion
extérieure me semble est une priorité si
on assume ça si on assume que les règles
composent quelle que soit leur ampleur
elle ne conduira pas à ce que des
produits qui viennent hors d'Europe
moins chers puissent concurrencer ce
qu'on fabrique ici vis-à-vis des
consommateurs on aura de toute façon une
difficulté à continuer à nouer une forme
de pack de confiance ou de pack tout
court avec des agriculteurs
ensuite je suis pas persuadé qu'on ait
besoin d'un troisème pilier nous pouvons
continuer un rééquilibrage entre le
premier et le deuxè j'entends ce que
pourrait être la tentation d'aller plus
loin mais là je vous avoue très
humblement
que ce n'est pas un sujet auquel j'ai
réfléchi mes autres responsabilités nont
pas donné de loisir de me pencher sur
cette perspective mais ça me rassure
pour mon pays
que des membres du Parlement en soit se
poser ces questions quand il travaill
sur ce type de sujet mais ce sera quand
moi je ferai une commission d'enquête
que je vous questionnerai l'un et
l'autre que je seraiis heureux d'avoir
vos réponses pour le moment je suis pas
capable de répondre de façon plus
précise
là-dessus
merci Monsieur le
Ministre alors pour des des raisons qui
m'échappent on a des membres de la
commission qui ont assister à à votre
intervention au premiers échanges qui
sont repartis donc je pense que nous
Pons prolonger rapporteur président
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez
d'autres questionsoute la
conversation mais je note déjà
l'engagement du ministre de l'écologie
contre le
Mercosur ça
c'est la méfiance partage tout à fait et
c'est c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
que vous l'exprimiez aussi clairement
aujourd'hui parce que discours du
gouvernement est parfois du président de
la République est plutôt plus ambigu sur
sur ce
sujet
deuxièmement on a vous parl des mesures
miroires des clauses miroir au fil des
débats certains nous ont alerté en N
disant mais ce qui devrait être
l'antidote au mauvais commerce peut
devenir le prétexte au mauvais commerce
puisqueon a des mesures miroires on peut
commercer avec le monde entier etchanger
des marchandises partout or l'efficience
de ces mesures miroir pose question on a
une hypothèse qui à peine esquissée dans
le plan gouvernemental j'aimeris avoir
votre opinion dessus c'est de dire quand
un pesticide est interdit chez nous
c'est limite maximale résiduelle égale à
zéro pour son importation qu'en
pensez-vous d'abord je
partage l'idée qu'il faut pas se tromper
d'indicateur et donc la clause miroir
elle vise non pas à ensuite totalement
se se dédoiner mais à faire en sorte
qu'on ait des qu'on ait des mises en
cohérence et donc j'entends l'argument
que il faut savoir jusqu'où ne pas aller
trop loin et C je dis juste que ça
devrait être une base et non pas un
sujet dont on débat thème par thème mais
que de manière générale quand on
applique des règles on explique
qu'effectivement elle Val pour
l'extérieur et donc très concrètement à
partir du moment où on exige de ceux qui
produisent ici un résidu zéro on peut
pas tolérer que le résidu ne soit pas
zéro pour ceux qui veulent vendre parce
que nos débats sur les pesticides en
Europe vous avez vous-même évoqué que
dans les bienfaits des plans écophyo il
y avait finalement eu une forme
d'information citoyenne de prise de
conscience et donc les gens sont
persuadés quand on explique qu'on
diminue un certain nombre de produits ou
d'usage que ça vaut pour ce qu'ils vont
ensuite trouver dans les points où ils
vont chercher leur propre alimentation
le fait de ne pas avoir de close miroir
ça peut participer à une manière
d'induire en erreur nos concitoyens
parce qu'ils ont entendu des débats et
des interdictions et ils pensent de
bonne foi que on peut pas se retrouver à
acheter des produits qui comportent des
choses qui ont été interdites par leurs
représentants vous nêtes pas fermé à
cette idée d'une d'un durcissement d'une
capacité de de contrôle sur place qui
suppose des moyens redéployés par
l'Europe et même d'une hypothèse que
jeis en train de d'évaluer qui serait
une sorte d'inversion de charge de la
preuve pour ceux qui qui qui
impimportent qui qui exportent chez nous
parce que après tout est-ce que c'est au
contribuable européens que de financer
le contrôle voilà c'est je je on est
dans des réflexions mais on pense que le
statut qu l'ambigué sur ces débats je
crois que ça nous le partageons
contribue à une sorte de découragement à
la fois des consommateurs des
producteurs et et finalement des
citoyens donc une clarté est attendue
sur ces sujets je vis encore traiter
deux sujets d'ouverture avec vous si
vous le voulez bien le premier c'est
celui de la recherche on poursuivra le
dialogue avec votre collègue ministre de
la recherche et l'enseignement supérieur
demain mais j'ai eu l'occasion d'en
échanger au pied de l'émicycle avec elle
il y a pas vraiment de de programme
européen oneelse à notre à notre
connaissance une seule santé il y a des
programmes euh français portés par le
ministère de la Santé porté par vous des
programmes de recherche qui sont en
cours qui sont suggérés financiers et
cetera il y a des dispositions
onusiennes à travers les coopérations
entre l'OMS la FAO et
l'oie l'organisation vétérinaire mais il
nous semble j'aimerais avoir votre
savoir sur le sujet qu' une sorte de
chînon manquant qui a une architecture
européenne en la matière vous
semble-t-elle
souhaitable je crains que vous n'ayez
raison je je suis en train mentalement
d'essayer de de de faire la liste des
dispositifs que je que je
connais
je ne pense pas spontanément à des
exemples si verou sera beaucoup plus
qualifié que moi pour être capable de
vous répondre mais c'est vrai que je
n'ai pas souvenir qu'on a évoqué devant
moi des programmes de recherche
européens ou de d'autres pays pour
encourager ou prendre une décision dans
un
domaine des gros enjeux sur les sur les
débats sur les agences
an FFSA c'est la question de leur prise
en compte de
l'exposom des effets cocktails de tout
tout tout ce qui est on va résumer ça
par l'exposom quand or on ne peut pas
appréhender cette question de l'exposom
si on n pas progressé dans notre
capacité à mesurer des impacts
multifactoriels dans le temps et pas
seulement issu de l'Agriculture et
cetera et cetera donc ce déficite de
connaissance en la matière qui nourr par
une recherche fondamentale une recherche
appliquée et disponible pour pour les
agences sanitaires nous parit
particulièrement heureux je sens que
vous y souscrivez en tout cas bien
sûr
d'autant que l'absence de programme de
recherche européen peut conduire à ce
que ce soit les acteurs qui sont
eux-mêmes sur la C sur un certain nombre
de dispositifs qui fournissent les
seules données sur lesquelles ensuite se
base la
décision on y av un petit peu pensé et
on va s'intéresser dans les jours qui
viennent à évaluer l'ensemble de la
recherche privée et le poids de la
recherche publique en la matière sur la
question de la la moindre dépendance et
l'évolution de la phytopharmacie j'en
reviens permettez-moi sur peette
dernière
question euh sur sur la question de
l'eau vous avez vous avez dit votre
attachement votre importance vous avez
pas évoqué vous avez évoqué les je
recherche not pgse mais une fois qu'on a
fait un pgse je crois que c'est je suis
pas sûr mais les agences 70 % des
captage ne dispose pas de pgse vous
confirmeriez
l'ordidé plus moins 50 % 50 % d'accord
bon d'accord ok peut-être c'est un autre
dispositif à 70 % je je prends je prends
les je prends le 50 %. une fois qu'on a
fait un pgse il faut agir alors il y a
un dispositif il y a or or en je sais
pas comment on le prononce ore qui est
intéressant il y a des dispositions de
préemption foncière mais peu efficient
il y a pas de vente du terrain on est
d'accord et puis a les Z zsce euh donc
vous dites dans le plan écofyo 2030 que
vous allez les activer de façon plus
volontaire queles sont les freins
aujourd'hui pour votre ministère à la
nonactivation de ces Zid SC ce qui
semble pour les agences de l'eau une des
dispositions les plus prometteuses est-
la faute de l'ARS des préfets euh
qu'est-ce qui ne fonctionne pas pourquon
les mettre pas en
œuvre les zsce c'est-à-dire les zones
sous contrainte
environnemental on va
pas faciliter leur
usage nous allons le systématiser
dépassement égal fermeture automatique
c'est ça qui est dans le plan haut du 30
mars oui mais c'est une verticalité qui
est pas sur l'préemption ou sur la
conversion agroécologique qui est de
dire vous dépassez les seuils on est sur
des impératifs de santé il y a donc
l'arrêté préfectorale de fermeture du
captage qui tombe de manière automatique
j'ai besoin de mon pgse en amont j'ai
besoin d'avoir les outils de lever et
dans les semaines qui viennent je pense
avant Noël nous aurons la la publication
de ces instructions de manière très
claire sur cette activation automatique
des ZS ce on
a un peu plus de 30000 captages en
France on en a 3000 à la minute où nous
parlons qui sont fermés pour des raison
sanitair et et vous mesurez que au
travers d'un dispositif de de ce
type
il on va évidemment totalement changer
le notre niveau de protection et celui
de nos concitoyens et renforcer
l'intérêt d'avoir des mesures dans les
faits ces zsce ell fonction avec un
système gradué où on on pose d'abord des
contraintes de suivi on laisse une forme
de temps c'est pas un coup près qui
consiste à dire demain matin vous coupez
tout et vous vous débrouillez pour aller
trouver de l'eau potable pour vos
concitoyens en revanche le dépassement
entraîne de manière automatique des
dispositifs de contrainte de suivi qui
permettent pour la préfecture et pour
les différents partenaires de pouvoir à
ce moment-là prendre des mesures imposer
des mesures y compris sur les
intrants de manière à ce qu'on revienne
à une situation normale mal qu'on
repasse sous les seuils de manière à
pouvoir sortir de cette procédure de
suivi on aura l'occasion de vous
présenter si vous le souhaitez de
manière un peu plus spécifique le
dispositif mais c'est un point clé et je
le redis qui a pas été totalement vu
quand on a présenté le plan parce que
tout le monde était focalisé sur les
fuites sur la réutilisation des EAU usé
sur la question des moyens sur les
plafonds mordants sur plein de sujets
sur la question aussi de la
gouvernance parce
que la multiplicité des plans la
multiplicité des zones de captage et ces
zones sous contrainte environnemental
sont un sont un bon exemple avec cette
autom cette automaticité de l'arrêté
préfectoral en cas de dépassement de
seuil montre que pour avoir un système
résilient on ne peut pas continuer à
avoir 12000 gestionnaires d'eau potable
dans ce
pays parce que si chacun d'entre eux ne
gère qu'un point de captage et que vous
retrouvez avec une difficulté de ce type
c'est le schéma de distribution qui
s'écroule d'où la nécessité
d'intercommun iser ses dispositifs de
s'appuyer sur plusieurs de conduire des
euh des circuits de sécurisation qui
permettent de reboucler sur plusieurs
usines et cetera et cetera je reviens
pas dans le détail mais très
concrètement c'est la philosophie et la
philosophie c'est bien de tenir compte
de cette évolution et d'assumer une
cohérence on ne se contente pas d'avoir
des éléments d'observation si on dépasse
les seuiles d'observation arrêter
préfectoral mesure de contrainte suivi
et si ça suffit pas
fermeture c'est la chaîne
alors j'avais dit c la dernière question
mais la question des des tuyaux de de
financement vous avz mobilisé de la RPD
elle va servir un fond 250 millions dont
tout le monde s'interroge sur ce dont ce
à quoi il va le servir on vient on vient
de débattre le mot est n'est pas adapté
on vient d'essayer de débattre du du
budget l'annonce de 250 millions on peut
pas y être hostile à priori mais on
aimerait participer au débat quoi est-ce
que c'est de la techn tion est-ce que
c'est est-ce que c'est de l'agronomie
est-ce que c'est un changement de
système est-ce que c'est bon on sait pas
personne ne semble trop savoir je suis
pas sûr que que finalement on sache mais
on a annoncé 250 millions quand on prend
le rapport d'inspection qui a été publié
un petit peu sous la contrainte en
2021 qui reprend l'ensemble des
financements écofitau il est pointé par
l'ensemble des inspections le fait que
véritablement une usine à gaz qui a
beaucoup de de pert et qui a pas de
gouvernance partagée le délégué
interministériel lui-même nous a dit que
pour avoir une politique
interministérielle fallait-il encore
qu'il y a une politique enfin pour avoir
un délégué interministériel et une
politique commune il fallait une
politique interministérielle c'est pas
le cas mais quand on rege les
financements c'est encore pire c'est ce
que dit l'inspection c'est incroyable
entre les agences qui aujourd'hui sont
amenés à financer parfois la bio à 100 %
sur des territoires par défaillances des
autres moyens du ministère de
l'Agriculture entre
euh ce que font les agences dans un
dialogue qui est pas toujours parfait
avec les autres politiques d'cofito et
cetera et tout on a l'impression que
tout ça n'est pas bien gouverné les
circuits financiers sont sont pas
opaques mais ils sont complexes euh
c'est une agence de l'eau qui collecte
euh qui redonne les résultats on a les
résultats des cofitau en terme
d'indicateur 1 an et demi après l'argent
est redistribué ensuite au ministère
enfin personne enfin franchement
l'inspection conclu à quelque chose euh
d'incroyablement comp x avec beaucoup de
perte d'énergie l'absence d'un
commandement centralisé à la fois sur
les sources de financement et la manière
de dépenser cet argent et et sur le
pilotage stratégique des cofitau est-ce
que vous admettez qu'il a une
défaillance majeure et que rien dans le
plan éco fito 2030 tel que présenté par
le gouvernement ne
permet d'envisager qu'à terme il en soit
autrement
vot commission d'enquête
elle arrive précisément un moment où on
train on est en train de de finaliser
d'ajuster des dispositifs donc le moment
où elle rendra ses conclusions pourra
aussi éclairer l'interministérialité
dont vous êtes en train de questionner
des limites par rapport au plan
précédent donc j'ai pas toutes les
réponses parce qu'on a obtenu des
engagement financier le calage par
exemple de la manière dont on va ajuster
ces sommes est-ce que on les arrête pour
une année est-ce que c'est l'année 2024
entre guillemets sur laquelle on a une
maquette et qu'on s'autorise ensuite à
ce que les choses puissent bouger on a à
la fois besoin d'avoir un budget qui
soit ambitieux pour montrer qu'on prend
ce sujet au sérieux et en même temps
sans doute de garder une part de
souplesse et d'humilité parce que on
aura des besoins en début de période qui
correspondra forcément à ce qu'on verra
ensuite donc
là-dessus ce que je veux dire je vais
pas vous renvoyer la balle la fin de de
de de cette audition mais un peu quand
même autrement dit on n'arrête pas un
plan qu'à voocation être gravé dans le
marbre s'il y a bien une chose qu'on a
retenu de ces 15 dernières années c'est
la nécessité d'être humble par rapport
au sujet d'avoir une ambition et une
détermination qui ne varie pas et qu'on
est capable de renforcer ou de
repositionner dans le temps et puis
d'être ouvert à des points d'étape en
attendant pas le dernier jour du plan
pour regarder ce qu'on doit bouger et
donc au moment où vous aurez l'occasion
de nous dire ce qui vous semble pour
vous être des éléments qui expliquent le
succès ou qui au contraire ont
relativisé une partie des résultats je
je ne vois pas comment ça ne donnera pas
la matière la manière la matière pardon
nous de pouvoir aussi déplacer des
curseurs regarder comment on peut tenir
compte des conclusions de cette
commission parce que vous l'avez dit en
commençant il y a pas seulement une
interministérialité il y a
globalement un positionnement qui est
interpolitique si j'ose dire
interpartisan et et qui dépasse une
partie de ce que peutv être nos clivages
là-dessus on peut avoir ensuite des
questions sur le rythme sur les
alternatives mais globalement on est sur
une orientation globale euh qui n'est
pas
euh qui n'est pas un acte d'opposition
qui est très partagé et et donc de ce
point de vue aidez-nous à regarder
comment on peut préserver une partie des
acquis et aller plus loin en efficacité
à la jonction de cette
interministérialité monsieur le ministre
un grand merci pour la qualité de vos
réponses le temps que vous avez pris
avec nous
euh voilà ça avait vraiment du sens de
d'avoir cette audition en fin de
parcours pour nous
euh parmi toutes les personnalités que
nous auditionnons et donc merci encore
pour votre venue je vais lever cette
cette séance et vous informer que nous
aurons notre dernière audition demain à
16h30 bonne soirée à
tous